let's hear from some folks in the
audience we're getting close to the end
of the year we will soon have a new
president what is on folks minds
you can talk to me through our discord
server davidpakman.com
discord let's go first
to kelsey from colorado
kelsey from colorado you're on the air
what's going on
hey david can you hear me yes i can
awesome
uh well hey i'm a big fan of the show
thank you been watching
ever since i think august so it's been
keeping me mentally sane
i love it um i guess my question is
what do you think is the end game for
um the republican party as a whole i
know they're kind
it seems like they're fragmented and i
saw
um the footage of ludo
lou dobbs and stephen miller kind of
figuring out what
what's happening and i'm just kind of to
see
what is the long game for them to
stay in existence because i i just don't
see it happening with
more people seeming to get involved in
younger generations coming
up um what do you think is their endgame
so you mean you don't mean just between
their their antics between now and
inauguration day for biden you mean like
really long term for the survival of the
party
because honestly like they'll keep going
but i think
it seems that more people are going to
get tired of it
yeah and um i i feel like it's not
sustainable so
i don't know if they're playing to just
reform or what the deal is but what do
you think is their in-game
you know people have been asking this
for so long and for a long time we now
we've been hearing the republican party
will eventually
go out of existence because subsequently
younger generations are more and more on
the left that reversed a little bit
because actually young voters supported
trump at a slightly higher level than we
would have expected relative to past
republicans in 2020 or
demographic changes including more
latino voters going to some key red
states are going to make those states
purple and eventually blue and the
republican party won't be sustainable
so far that's not happened now part of
the reason kelsey it hasn't happened is
voter suppression gerrymandering right
figuring out ways
other than winning the hearts and minds
of voters to keep winning by preventing
people from voting or whatever the case
may be
i think that the important takeaway is
predictions of the republican party's
demise
on demographic grounds have fallen
short for decades at this point so we
should not assume
that they will simply uh go out of
existence because of the platform i
i believe that they will it's not even
going to be reform but they will just
tweak and adjust to continue
raising a lot of money from donors on
key wedge issues
keep suppressing the vote and and they
are not going to go away what they will
look like in 10 or 20 years i don't
pretend to know
gotcha yeah that makes sense i feel like
they're i i
that's what my fear is is that the
reforming is just going to get more and
more
ensconced and um you're just gonna have
to fight harder to
resist that i i agree and in particular
now
with uh you know completely
propaganda-based news outlets everything
from
you know breitbart gateway pundit
newsmax oan which people
think are actual news it's going to be a
big fight it's going to be a big fight
we can't underestimate the importance of
that so
it's a big battle we have ahead of us
right right
well great thanks for uh taking my call
and talking to me
all right kelsey from colorado very much
appreciate that uh
that call a lot of the shirts you see me
wearing on youtube are actually made by
a company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but
most importantly just overall it makes
the shirt
fit much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also
has a specially designed collar that
won't fall down and lay flat which i
love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout